[Music]
foreign
I'm a professor at Duke University and a
developer educator at posit this year at
positconf I'm teaching a one-day
teaching data science Master Class I've
been teaching data science with r for
over a decade and I can't wait to share
everything I've learned over this time
about successful data science pedagogy
teaching with authentic tools and doing
so effectively and efficiently here are
the top three reasons why you should
take this Workshop
first reason is keeping up with the
evolving data science ecosystem is not
trivial keeping up with it and deciding
whether it's the right time to update
your curriculum to incorporate new tools
or new features of existing tools new
data sources or new workflows and doing
so while concurrently teaching can be
overwhelming this Workshop is designed
to share with you what's new in the land
of teaching data science with r and to
distill for you how you can Implement
these updates in your curricula second
successful teaching doesn't end with
successful curriculum design the
computational infrastructure you use for
your teaching is an equally important
part of a successful data science course
particularly if your definition of
success takes into consideration the
experience and enjoyment of your
students as well as of yourself in this
Workshop we'll tell quite a bit about
how to set up computational teaching
environments with posit Cloud as well as
other server-based tools how to use git
and GitHub for Version Control
collaboration and Azure course
management system and how to teach
reproducible authoring with quarto as
well as how to use it to build your
course materials and sites
and third this Workshop will supercharge
your learning and teaching prep in one
day of the workshop you will pick up a
wealth of information and tips that can
save you weeks and months of trial and
error on your own additionally you'll
meet a community of like-minded data
science Educators with whom you can stay
in touch beyond the conference one final
comment is that this year the teaching
data science Workshop is offered as a
one-day Workshop which means you can
focus on your teaching on one of the
workshop days and spend the other day
learning something you've been hoping to
make time for all year go to deposit.com
conference to register for this Workshop
as well as to find out about all of the
other fantastic workshops we're offering
at positcons this year looking forward
to seeing you in Chicago in September
[Music]